hey what's up my name's samuel leeds i'm
a property investor and this video is
all going to be about planning
permission how to get planning
permission permitted development buying
on green belt trying to find brownfield
sites all the ins and outs and the
detail of planning now i've brought in a
planning expert for this interview so i
think you're going to really enjoy this
if you enjoy the channel hit like
subscribe and chris thanks so much for
coming down pleasure so you are a
planning expert and you know you've
actually helped us recently on one of
our sites why don't you just give a
little introduction as to what our
planning consultant does okay well a
planning consultant essentially tries to
get planning permission so uh we run a
planning consultancy that reviews sites
tries to understand that the risks
associated with trying to get planning
permission trying to understand what you
can get planning permission for how you
can maximize it
um in certain circumstances we are
bought into to troubleshoot and try and
overcome a planning argument but our job
essentially is to guide developers on
getting planning permission which is the
all-important aspect of any property
development process i suppose well yeah
i mean as a property developer we all
know that prof the profits in the
planning most of the time and that's
that's where you get most of your profit
from so
why don't you give us an idea then like
if you're looking for sites so if i'm
out looking looking at pieces of land
i'm on google earth or nimbus maps
looking at all the different sites
what's the best way to kind of know
whether you're going to get planning or
not i know that's a big question
yeah i know it is but but or should we
say how how would you even go about
finding these or if you're a
self-builder
what's the best way to go about finding
these kind of little beautiful um plots
okay a lot of it is common sense okay so
um
the first port of call is is
understanding the designations of the
area you want to live in okay so i'm
assuming in this circumstance that any
uh land hunter understands the general
areas they want to build in they they
come to that conclusion themselves for
whatever reason and then it's all about
understanding the designations of that
area so for example um a region will
have multiple different
planning designations you'll have land
that sits within sort of these arbitrary
imaginary red lines that are classed as
the settlement boundaries they're the
main built up areas for town cities and
villages and then you've got the areas
that sit outside of it i know it's often
that land that's more attractive to
people because ultimately either the
land's cheaper it's green fields it
gives you the opportunity to do a little
bit more than you would be able to if it
was the landing side of the boundary but
that land is uh is caveated by a huge
swathe of different designations so
whether that be green belts whether
there'd be open countryside
uh whether it'd be a conservation area
national park etc
so it's all about understanding the
ramifications of trying to proceed with
any of those sites as a rule of thumb
the closer the site is to the settlement
boundary the more sustainable it's
likely to be
if it's open countryside rather than
greenbelt it's policed to a slightly
lower level so it's more likely in
principle to get planning permission if
you were to try and balance things out
yeah and then it's all about the common
sense stuff the physical layouts of the
land so
you want to look at parts of land that
are
you know relatively unisolated so
surrounded by or yeah within reasonable
distance of other properties has a
distinct access has access through to
services and facilities etc so when
you're looking good google earth that's
what you're looking for yeah
then in terms of um
sort of other scenarios that you can
take advantage of it's just all about
doing due diligence so if land becomes
available or you become aware of land
it's doing the due diligence against it
it's checking the planning policies
which you may require a planning
consultant to help you with yeah
it's understanding if there's any
environmental designations etc that
offer a red flag against it so
unfortunately
there's no one answer and unfortunately
it's hugely caveated by
region to region differences
um
but the one thing i'd take away is the
fact that
every land has got a clear designated uh
policy position right so understand what
that is and then really work on the
basis of if i were to build a house here
or a couple of houses here how would
that sit in the land could i get away
with it yeah could i offer the benefits
that could push it over the line yeah
and i think if you understand that
that'll get you the vast majority of the
way there and the rest is you know the
stuff that you're more well-versed than
me samuel i'd say you know well i mean
i'm going to get on a little bit later
on to sort of things like understanding
the local plan green belt
identifying brownfield sites but i think
that i usually say to people when
they're just starting out is first thing
is to just use your common sense like if
there's a piece of land can you imagine
there being houses built on there is
there access how are people gonna you
know are there other houses around if
it's just in the middle of nowhere then
it probably won't and i know that's a
very very very simplistic approach but
it's the correct one the vast majority
of the time you know if um it's sort of
a sliding scale of um of impact right so
um you can have a parcel line that sits
in the green belt but if it sits a
hundred meters from the development
boundary associated with a settlement
you could in
all reasonable aspects walk out of the
land go and use its services and
facilities then that's obviously going
to have a substantially lower impact
than if the land is three miles away
from the nearest settlements high on a
hill and you build a house and it sticks
out like a sore thumb so yeah it is
there for interpretation and it is there
to
you know to present itself as a position
where if you apply common sense it will
get you along a long way along the way
and also we're in an interesting time
right now with the internet because
everything is online now i know it might
be difficult to
get the answers online it can be like
finding a needle in haystack but when
you talk about the the boundary where
the boundary is again that's on the
internet you can you can you can search
for this stuff
so you can find it so with a lot of due
diligence and if you're looking at if
you're a serious property developer and
you want to find sites in one particular
area you've got to spend a few weeks
just really understanding the rules
certainly yeah and a lot of it a lot of
it is available for you to see right a
lot of the information is simply going
on the local planning authority's
website or the local council's website
into the planning section they'll have a
planning policy section there'll be a
series of maps that will show you the
classifications of different policies of
land
search through it read the policy in
question you'll start to build up a
picture of what you can and can't do in
certain areas
and then just go and look at other
planning applications in the area and
see how
how they've managed to get something
across the line and again you can start
building up a picture of is it viable is
it is it possible even for us to get
planning permission here and if it is
this is the way we've got to go about it
and then i guess it goes down to having
a team as well like
you you shouldn't ever try and do
everything on your own you should always
have experts consultants around to be
able to kind of um do more further due
diligence on your on your behalf i
believe that anyway i think would be
you'd be mad to try and put forward
planning applications without having a
planning consultant for example
obviously i'm biased right but i think
so the
planning is so front loaded these days
in terms of the costs you know you've
got
a ridiculous amount of surveys that are
not cheap
you've got a planning application fee
which is not cheap architectural plans
which are not cheap so there's a lot of
money on the line with every application
you make
and ultimately a lot of the time all
you're doing is trying to balance cost
risk and you're trying to understand
okay in my particular circumstances
what is the cost that i can take on
board and i'm prepared to to risk
against this site but the all important
question therefore is what's the risk
you know what are the chances of getting
planning permission
and ultimately that question can only be
answered by a few people really because
you you want to take advantage of
experience
to to provide that information and
usually that's either a planning
consultant if the case is particularly
tricky and in some circumstances an
architect who maybe has experience of
delivering within that area as well so
yeah um yeah it's important to get that
extra information one of the things a
lot of my subscribers and students are
absolutely crazy obsessed with at the
moment it's permitted development
because and there's been some recent
changes just last year in what you can
do and there's a lot more things that
you can do with permitted development
rights so would it be right if you maybe
just share
what permit development rights is and
maybe explain some of the things that
you can do because people would assume
you have to get planning and it's it's
crazy how much you can do right now
without getting planned permission so
yeah maybe give us a little deep dive
into that i i will as far as i can as
far as i can okay so so permitted
development or pd as we as we generally
call it as most people call it who who
deal with it so it is um the ability to
do things without planning commission
ultimately um
it's governed by a slightly separate
piece of legislation to what a planning
application is
but a lot of the time you still have to
meet a certain provision of conditions
and the difference between pd and a
planning application is that if you meet
those conditions you are automatically
allowed to get on with that work
but the different the other difference
is if you don't meet any of those
conditions you can't overcome it with
other arguments or sort of reshape the
narrative in the same way you kind of
planning application so it's a lot more
black and white it's a lot more yes and
no which has its benefits and drawbacks
in terms of what you can do
um well in terms of householder work or
householder improvements or home
improvements
you've got the ability to make uh to
make changes by way of extensions
whether it be single story rear
extension single story side extensions
in some circumstances double story rear
extensions
now the the amount of depth that you can
do in those circumstances is predicated
by the approach so in some circumstances
you can go
three meters you know back to your
terrace or semi-detached property
without any planning permission four
meters for detached property there is
another mechanism again try not to make
it too complicated but where you can go
back six meters for a terrace or
assembly touch property and eight up to
eight metres for a detached property but
then you have to tell the council you're
intending to do it and give them notice
to be able to determine whether you can
or not that's a huge extension though
there huge and and you know building
back i mean you're adding a lot of value
to the house and and this is the thing
you know when you see this is what what
i look out for if i'm in a street and i
can see that there's some houses that
have already done it and they might be
selling i was i was in london recently
and there was those properties the
housing was home for like 1.6 1.7
million and they'd all been built back
they've been built they've been brought
back the detached houses they've been
brought back four meters in on some
instances double yeah um dormers at the
top and there was some 1.6 million and
then i was looking at this house that
was on for one million open to offers
and i'm thinking well i know i'm gonna
get permitted development rights to do
it it's been done in the street it's
only probably gonna cost a couple
hundred thousand but it's gonna
significantly increase the value of the
house normally there'd be a little bit
of a will i get planning though but when
you know the there's plenty development
in the area it's it's it's almost like
um a big win for property investors it's
a huge comfort because planning takes
time and it's risky she takes it off the
table the entire point of the the
current version of pd was bought in off
the back of the 2009 crash the idea was
to try and reinvigorate the
essentially building operations in the
uk
and so they took the decision okay well
with the small scale stuff if we think
that we're going to give you planning
permission anyway we may as well just
let you get on with it
and that's what that does and there are
other types of pd you've got in terms of
value added to properties you've got the
class e which is out buildings which can
often be hugely advantageous because in
some circumstances
you have the ability to build up to 50
of your rear garden space as an art
building um you know if you're building
things like gyms or summer houses
offices etc all of those ancillary
functions to the house you can really
add you know gain added value without
the need for permission there and then
you step outside the house and there are
other pd rights so you have the ability
to convert agricultural bonds into
houses in certain circumstances and the
most recent one was class m a which came
to play last year and that is the
ability to
change existing commercial units into
residential units which is the one that
you know the press are calling the
transformation of the high street yeah
it's hugely caveated but there are
certainly opportunities there to you
know to
to change
you know tired office space has not been
used into you know
highly valuable inner city residential
development you know so tell me then in
what instances because i know permitted
development isn't always um permissible
if you're in article four or in a
conservation area like this house for
instance i can't i can't i can't get
permitted there's no got it here no i
haven't got it here i'm trying to get
plunged to do some stuff but
in what instance would you need to get
planning permission to convert offices
into residential houses or whatever in
what uh series would you need to get
planning permission yeah
so if it's considered that the uh the
conversion
um
could in principle have an impact upon
um
what's called the quiet enjoyment or the
commercial enjoyment of the surrounding
guerrilla which is relatively ambiguous
right yeah what it generally means is
um if the council think that you taking
advantage of pd rights to convert an
office to a house will have serious
ramifications on either the uh the rest
of the commercial street
or on the occupiers of the property
itself then they'll ask for you to get
planning permission instead yeah and it
doesn't mean to say you won't get
planning permission what it means is it
allows them to put a closer critical eye
on what you're intending to do
it'll put greater responsibility on you
to bring forward more detailed
architectural plans to show that the
inhabitants can occupy the property in a
way that works for the high street and
to show that it doesn't impact upon the
value of the high street itself so the
class m8 is quite tricky right because
it was brought out and there's a lot of
noise around it to say okay this is
going to transform the high street but
it's hugely caveated which means that in
each and every case you need to make
sure that you've actually got pd rights
and if you haven't then you need
planning permission
so question then if you're doing a
conversion it's let's say a commercial
to a residential conversion and you
think you're going to get permitted
development rights watch the actual
process of i've been able to do that
okay so in that circumstance um
there is a need for a lawful development
certificate anyway okay but to take it
back
uh if you're doing any sort of pd that
requires the degree of what's called
prior approval essentially that process
is you you have to notify the authority
of the council anyway that you're
intended to take advantage of your pd
rights yeah so it's almost a notice to
confirm your intent to use it but that
notice gives the council a period of
time to check that you're recording with
those conditions so you treat it almost
like a planning application but it's a
planning application where you've got
one foot through the door
so you present to the local authority a
series of plans
um an intention of what you intend to do
and then you tell them how you're
abiding by the particular conditions of
that pd right
and then they'll have a period of time
to be able to determine themselves
whether you recorded that process or not
and if you record with the conditions
yeah then
essentially you're told you have
permitted development rights and you can
crack on with it
if you don't then they'll say these are
the reasons why you don't according to
this particular condition and what it
means is the key thing is it doesn't
mean to say you couldn't get planning
permission for it it just means to say
that you do need planning permission for
it yeah so there is there is a pro in
most circumstances there is a process to
go through that involves the council
unfortunately yeah um but at least what
that does is it gives you the paperwork
to be able to put into the title plan or
whatever you're doing right it allows
you to
um to be able to turn around and say if
you then sell the property you've got
the paperwork to say everything's been
done in the legitimate manner
if you're using pd rights where you
don't need to contact the council to
start with and you just go ahead and do
it at some point you're going to have to
do what's called the lawful development
certificate to say that you did that
work lawfully at that particular time
and that needs to be done before you
sell the property because then you need
to be added into the title pack right so
there is always a step one way or the
other is always a step
the benefit of not having to go through
that starting process or the council
initially is that you
can crack on it allows you to a certain
extent it allows you to get on with
things but in the knowledge at some
point in the future you're still gonna
have to regularize it for the benefit of
you know completing the title of the
property yeah
so what's the difference then chris
between greenfield sites and green belt
because that's something that a lot of
people get confused over there is a
difference yeah so so basically anything
outside of a settlement boundary is
greenfield okay so anything that sits
outside of these arbitrary imaginary
lines is classed as greenfield and these
lines these the settlement boundaries
how do you find these how do you how do
you get hold of how do you know where
the boundary is the easiest way of
finding them out is is on your local
authority's website unfortunately as
i've said before the over 300 local
planning authorities in the uk right all
with their own systems yeah with their
own intricacies quirks etc so there's no
one consistent place to look
but the the easiest place to go is local
authorities websites right into the
planning section into the planning
policy section and one way or another
you'll see these settlement boundary
plans right and so what you're looking
at okay is
if there's a parcel land you're looking
at you can see okay we sit outside of
the development boundary so it's
greenfield because it's not within the
where where the houses are so it's it's
it's greenfield but green belt different
what's that then so
when you're in the green field you're
then subject to
another classification on top of it so
greenfield is almost like a description
word of in or out but then on top of
that you've got the individual
designations so i've mentioned open
countryside for example yeah open
countryside is land in the green field
that isn't otherwise protected okay so
it's just classed as open countryside
greenfield land green belt
has a different function so greenbelt is
um originally meant to be a sort of a
band of green a belt of green that sits
around town cities and villages to try
and protect it from sprawl so to try and
police it in a greater manner to stop
those places from growing
it carries other functions but its
general approach is that if you're
looking to build in the green belt it's
substantially harder to get planning
permission because there is an actor in
policy there is actually presumption
against you doing it except in certain
circumstances
so in order to get planning commission
in the green belt the vast majority of
the time you need to provide us with
very special circumstances which are a
collection or a singular material
benefit that is sufficient enough in its
weights to outweigh the policy harm
right so the policy harm is if you want
to build a house in the green belt it's
substantial weight against
your case okay so substantial policy
position against it and i always use
these imaginary weighing scales right so
you've got this this meaty negative dis
benefit against you and you've got to
try and outweigh that with either one
singular benefit or multiple different
benefits yeah and they can be
the particular physical characteristics
of the site maybe it's been developed
before in a different manner maybe it's
got a whole host of buildings on that
you can squeeze down into one new
building
maybe it's the need lack of housing need
in a certain area maybe it's ecological
benefits that you can show maybe it's
green principles that you can bring
forward maybe it's the design itself
that's outstanding enough and it's often
a combination of these factors
so each and every green belt case is
different um because statistically it's
very hard to get planning permission
yeah so it's all about really
understanding how to knit together a
narrative to provide that beneficial
weight so if you're looking at land to
build on statistically it's much harder
to build in the green belt than in the
open countryside
um in both circumstances you still need
to push the envelope a little bit in
terms of how you're going to get
planning permission i had a friend
recently reach out to me and he was
saying um talking about paragraph 55
where if you build something that's
outstandingly beautiful there are
exceptions where they sometimes will let
you build um
i told him that it would probably be
unlikely and the amount of money they'd
have to spend on this absolutely
incredible house like it was it's not
really a scalable plan for a developer
um what what is that rule i know it was
it came out was it margaret thatcher
that brought that in i think it was well
i mean it's a version of it's been out
for years and years and years okay so a
version of this idea that okay if you
bring something forward that is
particularly exceptional or outstanding
then that can provide a mechanism to um
to support it sounds like really a bit
of a ace card for really rich people
that just want to build their dream home
so so it was okay so it's a vault it's
it was for years yeah it's evolved a
little bit um
so it's so it's still referred to as
paragraph 55 it's not actually paragraph
55 anymore it's paragraph it's it's gone
forward twice and it's now paragraph 80e
oh wow which is really catchy right but
everyone knows it's paragraph 55 okay so
the the premises you're able to bring
something forward that originally was
both innovative and outstanding to a
sufficient standard that it justifies
its position within a locality now what
that meant is in the past you'll have
seen a lot of green principle the very
energy efficient houses well above the
expected standard they were so excellent
that they're able to justify their their
development in that location
what that evolved into
in 2012 onwards was a requirement to not
only not only be architecturally
outstanding but also be innovative in
the way it's been designed specifically
for that location so you needed to be
able to present a narrative to say okay
well architecturally this is the reason
why this works here so imagine ground
designs on steroids
it's stepped back again now okay so as
of 2021
the wording is actually reduced down
because the bar was getting so high that
it was impossible to reach the
definitions
we're actually now back in a position
where
development you bring forward no longer
has to be innovative it just has to be
designed to an outstanding manner
and it designed and to meet the
outstanding definition it's to say okay
well the design is absolutely
outstanding for the context of this
location yeah which means that
technically an architect could design
something in one location tweak it and
say it's still outstanding for this
location it's no longer compared against
that location because it's more
regionalized now which does give greater
opportunities to do it for
people that are millionaires which is
which is helpful and what you see what
we've seen over the course of the past
12 months is statistically
paragraph 80 development is occurring
more now um its success rate was crazy
low up until up until last year it was 1
10 it was like it was even lower than
that at some point at some points across
the time it was getting down sort of two
or three percent success oh my goodness
because the issue is it's a twofold
process right so what you do is you get
a design that you're happy with you take
it to a design review panel independent
panel of architects yeah who review it
and determine it as outstanding or not
they package up a letter and then it
goes to the local planning authority
with their support now a lot of the time
the issue was a lot of the cases were
going to them and they were disregarding
them so they weren't even getting to the
application stage but the costs were
there so when you look at when you take
you win and you look at it from here it
was like two percent it was crazy now
it's substantially increased because the
um
the barriers are reduced
so all of a sudden you're in a position
where you say okay well we haven't got
to do a floating house on some stilts
anymore you know to make something work
we can do something that is you know
it's it's architecturally superior
but it's not
ostentatious it's not ridiculous it's
not a teletubby house you know it's it's
something that's really high quality and
we're able to sell a narrative to make
it work yeah so all of a sudden it is it
is more opportunistic than it used to be
but it's still super expensive right and
it's not very scalable is it i don't
know there's no there's there's no
developers that i've ever met that say
this is my strategy um no most people
that do it are building their dream
houses yeah yeah it's not really a
process they're having to have to agree
about land and they want to build their
dream house i think if you're if you're
looking at as a as an actual business as
a property developer and you're scanning
green belt um
i would imagine you would probably
advise and agree on this
you want to be looking for brownfield
sites within greenbelt um so maybe you
could just talk about the definition of
brownfields because i didn't actually
know when i first started looking for
brownfield sites that
like agricultural barns and stuff
sometimes didn't even count so i ran
into some issues so i just want to be
really clear what what is categorically
a brownfield site how can you identify
it okay so try and give you a clear
definition when there's not one so the
the issue is that um
so so brownfield in its general term is
this idea of okay it's been previously
developed on yeah
but that's actually not true right but
what brownfield is it's something that's
been previously developed on to the same
appropriate use for its locality so let
me take a step back and i'll explain
what that means so if you're
take looking at a site within a city
and it's had a commercial office block
on or it's had a residential property on
it for example and it's been demolished
that's a brownfield site because what
you intend to use it for is a similar
type of use to what was on it before
okay
whereas an agricultural barn for example
that's never been used for a residential
or commercial purpose yes so that is
classed as previously developed land
it's it's had development on it but it's
never had developments on it there's
concurrence with what you wish to
develop it for
and so there's a difference between
brownfield and previously developed
brownfield gives you a mechanism to say
um it's encouraged to reuse brownfield
yeah okay so it gives you the basis in
which you say okay well in policy terms
by taking this previous commercial or
industrial unit knocking it down and
build the house on we're actually
reusing and recycling brownfield land
but with an agricultural bond what
you're doing is trying to say well we're
trying to make use of previously
developed land yeah it doesn't carry
doesn't carry the same window into the
developer into a developable position
so there are there are two separate
distinct definitions when it comes to
land with buildings on it and it's
really important to be honest that you
as far as possible try and
navigate yourself towards brownfield
land yeah if you're trying to make use
of previously developed lands to help
your case you're still going to have to
do that planning balance exercise it's
just one of the factors that could sit
in favor but it's not enough on its own
right so if you're looking at an
agricultural bomb
it's cool it's got a building on it
you're proposing you're building on it
so visually
it has less of an impact upon
the countryside but if it used to be
commercial then if it's previously
developed land and that land used to be
like maybe a factory or a dog kennel or
something like that and now it's been
knocked down vast majority of the time
that will be classed as brownfield or
even if it's on greenbelt you're still
going to be able to build on it right in
principle yeah so the
there is plenty of brownfield sites in
the green belt as there are plenty of
existing houses of the degree builds um
the green belt is the greenbelt's
predominant function is as i said to
protect urban sprawl but it's already
been built right
if it's really built upon it's it's no
longer protected i think as well it's
really important to know as property
developers that the council
they want developers to build houses
it's not like the council are there with
a big stick trying to fight off
developers they're actually they're
actually crying out some cities are
massively short on houses and it's quite
a clever system really because
the developers come find the sites they
get their sill tax
or whatever um so
i think it's really important to know
that when you're dealing with the
council although sometimes there can be
a pain it can be slow
there's a reason for them you know the
purpose is to make sure that the the
country stays attractive every you know
it's if everyone was just building on
green belt everywhere the country would
be a mess wouldn't it yeah so there's a
reason why planning policies exist i
think we've all got our frustrations
even me in the private sector are
planning got our frustrations with how
quick the council respond the quality of
some of the decision making but
ultimately the policies are there for a
reason right the policies are there to
try and make sure that
these areas are already built on are
maximizing what they can contribute yeah
and doing it in an attractive manner
and that that's the fundamentals of it
the vast majority of the development
within england and wales should be
located within these existing
settlements
if you're having to knock something down
to rebuild something which is more
attractive or increase its contribution
to the area by bringing more housing
forward
that's more of a holistic approach and
it is by constantly you know reusing new
greenfield sites and not improving
what's already there so the principles
are there the problem is that there are
always exceptions to the rule and it's
the exception to the rule that provide
the complexity the vast majority of the
time but yeah planning so basically
learn understand the planning rules
learn it but before this is my advice
before you just go and buy a site either
number one get a planning consultant to
look at all the different factors or
number two like i do because you know
buy it on an option
so
worst case if you can't get planning
you've lost a few thousand pounds but
you can then walk away um yeah both
circumstances you're mitigating risk
right you're either taking due diligence
in order to understand where the risk
lies or you know within an option
agreement which i highly recommend a lot
of the time for bigger schemes
you're giving yourself a cushion an
insurance policy if things don't work
out as the way you want them to you know
sensible and the on the schla as well
they'll say these are the sites
opportunities that their council are
actively wanting developers to come and
build um talk to me about understanding
the importance of understanding the um
the national
um planning policy framework what is
that and why should everybody read it as
boring as it is um
why should every developer
yeah classic 1990 pages of stadium well
look ultimately it is it is the
framework right so it's the it's the
central
narrative that the government provides
to
to inform all local plan policy
so each authority has their own local
plan with their own as i said their own
policies around quirks
but the issue you've got to remember is
that
the up-to-date nature of those local
plans varies from place to place and
often local politics plays a part for
example it's very difficult to actually
get these things constantly on the up
you know on the front foot so you could
be in a position where a local plan
could be 10 years old and the sites have
been allocated for housing have already
been done yeah there's nothing there so
the mpbf is there to provide the
shortfall where there is a lack of
upstate policies in in local terms but
it also provides the general aspirations
right so it tells us
politically it tells us where we are in
terms of where we see in the country and
at the minute the framework is a series
of paragraphs that essentially everyone
has to take on board when making a
planning application what it's currently
telling us is that there's a huge
shortfall in housing
and a lot of the paragraphs are there to
try and define
the appropriate approach to try and
cover that shortfall
there's no not much detail in
the mppf really that's why it's a
relatively easy read um but if i was to
you know to tell any of your viewers
where to start in terms of understanding
planning it's probably the best place to
start because it'll give you a flavor of
what is expected to be delivered when
you're doing any development um
yes that's what it is it's general
guidance which supplements local in
terms of the national um national
planning policy framework what's the
difference between that and the adopted
local strategic plan and why is it
important to read both
so local plannings are are the local
policies that are so if you've got an
area let's say your area is sandro
council yeah
that there's going to be a
a local plan for sunderland council and
then there's the national plan but if
you're looking to develop in sandwell
you need to be really aware of the local
strategic plan as well you need to be
aware of both right so so the the local
plan sandwell local plan which i'm quite
aware of yeah so that is a series of
site-specific and area specific
designations okay so it carries an
understanding of what the council
expects to see with regards to design
typology housing mix scale it tells you
what the conservation areas are for a
particular area if there's an area of
particular parking stress it does all
the local stuff right yeah but then it
has to be combined with the national
policy which is as i said is the broad
brush advice for that particular point
of time so for example sandwell for
years had a very decent five-year
housing supply position which is the
minimum requirement
but the national guidance has told the
councils that they need to keep on the
constant front foot with that and make
sure they keep delivering now if you
read the sandwell local plan on its own
you suggest okay well they're pretty
sorted in terms of their housing supply
right it's gonna be very difficult for
us to bring something forward
that may you know be trying to satisfy
need it's a planning argument but if
you're really in conjunction with the
mppf the national planning policy
framework you'll see actually that a lot
of those policies are currently out of
date so it's the reason why you need to
refer to both how how out of data is
sandwell
uh
not hugely outdated so there are there
are local plans which are from 1993
knocking around in the uk yeah so their
local plan i think don't quote me on
this i think it's 2015 so there's a lot
there's a lot of local plans that are
older than the national framework plan
most talk to me about the um the tilted
balance um
okay so in a circumstance where you
don't have a five-year housing supply
so let's say our local authorities and
that their job is to keep the government
up to date on what and what their
housing supply is
the magic number is five years okay so
if you have a five-year housing supply
um you are safe from further scrutiny
for that point of time until you
recalculate it next year and the way
that they calculate it is by all the
sites they give permission to and
anything that they've allocated for for
larger scale development that they think
is going to be developed at some point
so um so that's the approach if at any
point your development falls underneath
that magic five-year housing supply line
then what's called tilted balance
supplies okay so that is it it sounds
more dramatic than it is right so the
idea is that your plan falls silent and
it's it's a free-for-all
in reality that doesn't happen yeah what
it means is that um the amount of weight
that a local plant a local planning
authority can give to those housing
supply-specific policies falls away so
if for example they're saying that okay
site a
we don't want you to develop housing now
because in our view that should be
delivered for a commercial scheme yeah
an office block or whatever it is it
gives the developer the option to say
well hold your horses the priority of
the mppf is to deliver housing you don't
have the magic five of your housing
supply that policy currently falls
silent so it gives you again a leg in
the door to get something through what
it doesn't do and this is what's often
lost actually in the advice that's
currently out there in the ether it
doesn't give you the broad range to go
okay i'm going to crack on and develop
anywhere because other policies still
apply so the environmental policies
still apply for example right but it
helps if you're wanting to do a scheme
super helpful and
what about when they update their um
adopted local strategic plan do you
still does it suddenly get really tough
in that area or is it okay yeah so
usually for usually for
for a good two years
um what that does is it means that the
council have satisfied their housing
supply because what it does is when they
when their local plan is adopted
it's automatically assumed that their
five-year supply has now been bought
back up to date right so it means for a
period of at least two years
they're not under the pressure to
examine the delivery strategy so it's a
starting point we have a five-year
housing supply because we have a new
local plan there's nothing you can do
about it at year three of that plan
they'll need to start examining as to
how many of those sites they've
allocated and then that's when you want
to come in again that's when you guess
when you want to go in again right so
i wouldn't be hugely worried about
trying to make sure that a five-year
housing supply is dipped below that
magic line before you take a site
forward because there's often other
planning cases that can be presented but
if you're bringing forward a site that
you know is quite speculative and you
need that your golden ticket yeah then
it's all about timing so if you put
forward planning application and you are
declined and you and you fail which is a
really frustrating painful thing to
happen
um
talk to me about the appeal process
because of course you've got the right
to appeal which is part of the planning
application so it's free to appeal um
what's the what's the difference between
who do you then go to and what's the
approach of that and okay so it's all
slightly different another another admin
another yeah red tape i know this is
stuff that we've spoken about off the
camera because this just happened to us
yeah where we've had and you've been
really helpful in terms of your
advice try to because it's all about
managing risk right spreading risk as
far as possible so that
an appeal's made not to the local
planning authority right so you've had
that refusal from the local planning
authority you're annoyed with them your
application your appeal goes to the
planning inspector planning inspector
are a separate government body
they are completely independent from
local authorities
they're not regionalized they're not
politicized they have no engagement with
the local authority they are essentially
a pool of independent highly trained and
highly experienced planning consultants
who work as inspectors yeah they all
work in principle out of an office in
bristol but essentially are spread
throughout the country
you make it uh an appeal based upon the
reasons for refusal nothing else
so your ca you present what's called a
statement of case which is essentially
your planning argument against those
reasons for refusal everything else is
considered in common ground otherwise it
would have been a matter for refusal you
then submit to the planning inspectorate
system separate system
um the ins depending on the
circumstances either you'll put all of
the case load forward that went in your
original planning application with that
covering statement of case architectural
plans surveys etc or if it's a
householder appeal the council will do
that for you
it goes to the planning inspectorate the
planning inspector set a program and the
program is essentially the time frame it
takes for the inspector to review the
case and issue a decision themselves
um they'll the council will have a right
to respond to your stability case
throughout that program but then you'll
get the final say so you've got what's
called final comments against the
council's response to your response
and then there'll be another date where
the inspector comes out to see the site
after that date the inspector will issue
a decision the decision will either be
good news you've got plenty permission
we disagree with the council or it would
be sorry we disagree we disagree with
you um and we dismiss the appeal the
important aspect is if you get if they
grant you planning permission which the
inspectors can do happy days if they
don't what you tend to get is a more
prescriptive understanding of the
reasons why you didn't get the planning
commission in the first place and
inspectors often give you sufficient
information to say okay well if we do
this this and this right i'll take you
back to the council
because the council wouldn't do that
without the council when they get when
they refuse your planning permission
application they don't say but if you do
this instead it's not their job to come
up with schemes for you they'll they'll
tend to tell you where you've gone wrong
but they won't tell you how you can fix
it the inspectors a lot of the time will
give you that level of prescription and
the important thing is that then it's
not a scenario that the inspector's
decision is pitted against the council's
opinion the council have to take on the
inspector's opinion as the opinion okay
so if there are things you can take from
that appeal to repackage and you know in
a resubmission the council have to
accept them as as the starting point so
um so the evening uh appeals failing
there are often benefits that you
wouldn't get from the refusal of
applications worth feeling if you've got
a decent scheme i think so the downside
is time right so the time frames are
12 to 16 weeks and there's no real
correlation of speeding that up yeah so
the downside is time the but the upside
is it does mitigate risk why does
everything take so long in planning
because it's quite straightforward it
should be why does the average appeal
take six months
well most of the time is staffing
so the um
i'm not going to criticize the yeah
the public sector and how inefficient
they are because in certain
circumstances it's not their fault the
planning system struggles because there
is there is a lack of funding that has
been for for a while a lack of budgets
so the planners that do exist in our
environment simply get paid more in the
private sector than doing the public
sector so it's difficult to attract
staff particularly experienced stuff
but then on top of that um you you have
an issue of a lack of trained planning
consultant yeah and essentially a
planning officer is a planning
consultant so if you've got a lack of
them coming through the system there's
just the lack of because it can take
years can't it to get planning so we've
had cases you know not to
do our practice of this service at all
but we i mean we've had major cases that
have taken over two years to get
planning permission and it's not as if
there's been huge lulls in time it's
constant discussion negotiation to get
things through you just want to get
everybody in a room together and go
right come on folks that's what we're
doing yeah and a lot of the time you
know a lot of the things are addressed
just through that ability to communicate
directly the issue is that the processes
are such it's very difficult to get
that front face communication so the
advantage of getting planning is you can
make a lot of money and some of our
sites you know we've secured a site and
then we've got planning permission and
we've tripled the value of the site
and we haven't lifted a shovel you know
so it's a really good feeling when that
happens but at the same time it can be a
very long process um if someone's
wanting to
you know maybe do carry out some
extensions or build some houses and they
need a team
um at what point would would you
recommend bringing on a planning
consultant over an architect that says
oh i can give you some basic i can
liaise with the council when would you
say
no i need a planning consultant so the
easiest way to determine that and i'm
not one for you know parachuting
ourselves when we're not needed in a lot
of the smaller cases the architects
especially if they know the area they
can address things
planning consult but planning is also
there to address things where they're
more complex or
simply where just difficult to get
things through in one particular
location
the easiest way to know whether you need
it or not ultimately is to do a little
bit of due diligence yourself so
understand what you think the risks are
of the application try to be objective
with that and then if when you speak to
an architect you feel that they're maybe
underplaying things or being a bit
casual about it yeah then i think at
that point you say okay well perhaps we
just need to test the waters in terms of
cost risk i look in most cases i would
say it doesn't take much to contact the
planning consortiums and just ask them
for a little bit of broad brush advice
to start with most of them will provide
that relatively quickly
um you can then get a flavor from them
whether you think this actually this
site's more risky than we originally
thought
and if it is then you can make that
decision in conjunction with your
architect okay do we need that
additional support um
but we've all got our functions right i
can't draw um but i know pretty much
every single planning policy piece of
planning law in england and wales yeah
and architects you know
they can often get applications through
but it's often quite off the back of the
quality of their designs rather than
understanding how to play the policies
off against each other yeah
so yeah i would say most circumstances
you definitely need an architect you
don't definitely need a planning
consultant but if you feel that the case
is going to be more tricky than perhaps
everyone expects and that's when to call
us that's great well it's been a
pleasure having you on and you've been
an absolute fountain of knowledge so i
appreciate your time coming out um guys
i hope you enjoyed this deep dive into
planning and how to get planning
permission if you enjoyed the video
don't forget to hit it a like subscribe
and we will see you guys next time